I’m constantly amazed when other men have the audacity to call a woman names
like the B word or even other vulgar language
even if it's in a joking way,
if you as a man
have the audacity to call me a B word
ADIÓS
you're out of my life, like my dad
I don't care if it's a joke,
it's not funny,
if you're my man
then you should honor me and respect me and never call me out of my name
your role is to protect me,
not only that,
the idea of someone else calling me the B word should trigger you as a man
why are people thinking it's a joke or laughing at it?
it's not a joke and it's not funny
If you think we're too sensitive for feeling like this
then news flash
good men do not call women B words
Good men know right from wrong
we as women shouldn't apologize or make ourselves seem small
for wanting the basic respect and decency to not call us vulgar names
If you’re a respectful good man,
you wouldn't call us any names that are not our own.
It’s not cute, it's not funny
do not call us the B words.